Now, recall in the previous lecture, I
talked about the whole process of how we
think corners are an important
type of a feature.
And we actually looked
at this entire equation,
that basically gave us a way of looking
over an image by shifting it and
using that shifting to be
able to find a corner.
And again,
these were shifting the gradients.
Being able to move an image or
move a region over and
seeing if there's a change
in different directions, and
we computed all kinds of
information to support it.
So use it in this equation for
corner detection.
Just leverage the quadratic
approximation,
using the Taylor Expansion which
gives us another equation.
Which results in this simpler form,
and again it's not in a matrix and
vector form.
And M is the matrix that we
now actually want to compute,
because that'll allow us to do the
computations that we wanted to do here.
Just recall again,
M is the second moment matrix,
computed from an image using
derivatives Ix and Iy.
So again, we compute
the derivatives of an image and
using that we can actually
now compute a moment matrix.
And that allows us to now do this
computation in a much simpler manner.